oje aufs katy ist euer marx und herzlich
willkommen zur nächsten folge
minecraft nero ja es ist wieder soweit
und ich frag mich vielleicht tejo warum
nimmt er schon wieder auf der doch
gestern erst seinen ersten tod gehabt
ihr seht schon grund dafür
grund dafür ist ganz einfach dass ich
wieder belebt wurde vielen dank an
patrick an dieser stelle ich hoffe mal
das jetzt hier am spawn kein monster
lauert oder so er hat nicht wiederbelebt
der liebe per tritt und er sagte aber
oder bzw er hat mir leider gesagt dass
als ob er hat mir leider gesagt dass all
meine drops bzw
ja all meine items einfach verschwunden
sind
dk wisst ihr was das für ein serious
fucking problem ist dass gerade diese
gottverdammte bossgegner hier vorne sind
ich glaube ich kann um sie herum laufen
falls nicht bin ich so was von gst ich
glaube ich hab's geschafft okay ich bin
einfach wieder oben gelaufen aber das
sind halt des propheten die dinge die da
gerade sitzen detail die bossgegner so
von den charts und ich weiß nicht genau
wie viele lebenspunkte die haben aber
auf jeden fall richtig viel
und ja ich bin relativ froh dass jetzt
gerade um die herum gelaufen bin
patrick hat wie gesagt mir verklickert
was ich alles verloren habe dass ich
nichts mehr von dem ganzen zeug habe was
ich am ersten mal dabei hatte als ich
gestorben bin es halt wirklich für
unbeschreiblich dumm irgendwie das alles
weg ist und heute muss ich mich darum
kümmern dass sich halt irgendwie wieder
aufholen was ich letzte folge jetzt
durch meine eigene dummheit
zugegebenermaßen verloren habe es war
ein bisschen doof keine ahnung
die monster jetzt die anzugreifen weil
ich nicht so schlau dieser typ vor allem
ich dachte halt ich dachte halt relativ
viel muss ich sagen ich dachte dass das
irgendwie eine harmlose ab wäre die ich
da angreifen und ich freue mich so ein
bisschen strange
sind sie schon wieder darüber wie falls
ihr euch fragt warum so ein bisschen
strange kommentieren
grund dafür ist dass ich gerade ein
bisschen gefeiert habe weil ich meine
letzte schriftliche abitur geschrieben
habe ich gehe es erstmal zu meinem haus
und hoffe dass ich da irgendwie ein
bisschen essen bzw ausrüstung wir
organisieren kann
da ist uns glaube ich
warum ist ja noch mäßig so viel los
plötzlich bei uns in der stadt bern und
ist es sonst goldfinger ist es 225
lebens hat eigentlich nicht so viel
hey wies mich verarschen bist du mich
verarschen jetzt kommt schon bleibt auf
distanz und stirbt einfach mein gott
ich will jetzt nicht zu gott 2.0 haben
für tierhilfe sterben oman alter habe
ich etwas falsch gemacht jeweils nicht
vielleicht hab ich gerade einfach
schlecht geschlagen wie gesagt ich komme
gerade direkt vom feiern bin ich nicht
so ultra fit ist es nervig eigentlich
wäre heute meine wahl folge gewesen
deshalb sage ich jetzt halt einfach wen
ich wählen würde
ich würde patrick wählen so viel zu
anonymen wahlen ohmann okay das war's
macht's gut